bonjour à tous et bienvenue à l'heure
des proces matin Pierre Palmade Noël le
Great deux hommes deux destins que le
calendrier réunit dans la chute il y a
encore quelques semaines l'un et l'autre
brillait au firmament de leur univers
les voici à l'ombre pour l'éternité
l'époque regarde les hommes tombaient
l'époque jubile quand ceux qui avaient
tout non plus rien moins de 40 minutes
et puis s'en va aucune image de Noël le
grecte d'infiltrer ce matin seul ce
communiqué de la FFF acte à 11h30 la
démission de l'homme à sa tête depuis
2011 acculé de toutes parts en retrait
de la présidence depuis le 11 janvier le
menhirs vaciller certains lui prêtaient
une volonté de s'accrocher jusqu'au bout
d'autres annonçaient son départ sous
conditions sinon en Bundesliga on a vu
des supporters du Borussia monsion 4
bars et du Bayern Munich s'affronter
devant un match opposant leurs équipes
mais en silence zéro bruit interdit
[Applaudissements]
je pense qu'il y a eu beaucoup
d'émotions ce matin au sein du comité
exécutif et donc cette démission elle
permet aujourd'hui à la Fédération de
poursuivre sa marche en avant et à
levrette certainement de pouvoir mieux
se défendre se défendre face au
polémiques dérapages verbaux accusations
de harcèlement et une mission d'audit
accablante diligentée par le ministère
des sports
au revoir président
Nicolas Hulot Patrick Poivre d'Arvor ary
habitants Adrien cadenas Roman Polanski
Damien Abad Jean-Luc Lallet mais aussi
Isabelle et Patrick Balkany Jean-Jacques
Bourdin il ne s'agit pas de défendre
tous
ni de mettre selon l'expression tout le
monde dans le même sac tant ces
histoires sont dit semblables certains
ont mérité l'eau propre qu'il reçoive
compte tenu de son comportement
gravement inapproprié avec les femmes de
défaillance accentuées par une
consommation excessive d'alcool je ne
peux que faire mienne la conclusion du
rapport ils ne dispose plus de la
légitimité nécessaire pour administrer
et représenter le football français
j'observe simplement que l'espace
médiatique ne fait pas de quartier et
qu'il dévore ses affaires avec
délectation quand les dieux grecs
voulaient punir à mortel il lui donner
tout et lui reprenait tout avons aussi
qu'on récolte souvent ce qu'on sème et
qu'il faut bien un jour passer à la
caisse plus dur sera la chute et la
bande-annonce de l'époque fervent
défenseur du Mondial au Qatar il balaye
aussi les questions sur les droits de
l'homme et ose égratigner l'icône
Zinédine Zidane potentiel candidat à la
tête des Bleus
vous n'en ai rien à secouer je ne
l'aurais même pas pris au téléphone le
dérapage précipitera sa chute n'est pas
encore sa retraite à 81 ans Noël le
Grete va diriger le bureau parisien de
la FIFA un poste qui l'occupe depuis un
an déjà allez pour terminer l'image du
jour c'est Noël le grec qui fait sa
première réunion zoom avec ses nouvelles
collaboratrices de lapin je dirais qu'il
a une présence mal il se nomme le
barreur il se nomme le barreur je vois
bien la tempête dans la tempête regardez
cette nuit
on regarde la même chose magnifique vous
n'êtes pas obligé non plus de les
caresser
elle s'expose à moi comment faire
autrement dans quel film Brigitte Bardot
demande-t-elle tu les trouves jolies mes
fesses
oui je sais c'est troublant c'est
perturbant je pense
elles sont belles tes fesses Jean-Luc
pourquoi y a-t-il des cheminées qui
tirent bien et d'autres qui tirent moins
bien
c'est une question que vous vous posez
pas assez je je vois dans votre regard
et c'est vrai je me suis jamais posé la
question parce qu'il y a des bons et des
mauvais vendeurs de cheminée
certains y verront de la convivialité
d'autres de l'apaisement un feu de
cheminée mais dans votre écran de
télévision les Français seraient de plus
en plus nombreux à opter pour les
flammes virtuelles
illustration dans le Vaucluse où ce
jeune étudiant a depuis quelques
semaines adopter la cheminée fictive
ça donne une petite ambiance et ensuite
je me pose dans le canapé j'imagine que
pour qu'elle tire bien il faut bien la
ramener
exactement
voilà c'était la chronique de Fabien
mais j'ai enchaîné sur
ta sur ta blague merci Fabien parce que
c'est pas qu'un jeu c'est aussi de
l'humour
[Rires]
la réforme des retraites pour moi c'est
une question d'équité de justice pour
les générations qui viennent imaginons
qu'il lit la guerre un jour chacun devra
constituer une armée et nous plus on
sera nombreux plus notre armée sera
grande et plus on aura des chances de
remporter la guerre vous comprenez ce
que je veux dire c'est important de
faire des enfants
impressionnant de vidéo trouver sur Tik
Tok la vidéo du IRM d'un bébé en train
d'être allaité donc en direct live
qu'est-ce qui se passe au moment de
l'allaitement et bien regardez c'est un
médecin qui a mis ça en ligne et
regardez on voit très clairement le sein
à droite le bébé à gauche et le lait qui
entre dans le corps du bébé rien d'autre
à dire de plus que waouh j'ai cette
gosse 18 petits enfants alors il y a que
moi qui fait la cuisine en ce moment je
suis un peu fatigué j'en ai marre
il demande combien tu en as aucun
j'ai besoin de rencontrer quelqu'un pour
en faire d'abord non
je vais te trouver une femme moi la pire
chose qui pourrait arriver à un mariage
c'est l'autre que l'autre dise non mais
sinon moi j'ai trouvé un peu pire c'est
d'arriver à une femme en Chine elle
était sur le point de fouler le tapis
rouge lors de son mariage main dans la
main avec son jeune mari là on les voit
les deux sauf que non pas une mais 12 de
ces ex petit ami en débarqué avec une
banderole en main où il y a écrit nous
sommes les ex de Chen song donc le marié
et nous allons lui pourrir la vie